they make it their business to mind your
business
a Connecticut bill without lot ear
piercings for anyone under age 12 in a
Maryland school district wants to forbid
adults from hugging children other than
their own
sitting Ayers County Public Schools
moved to bar scenes like these in an
effort to keep kids safe after public
outcry the superintendent said the hug
ban was merely a recommendation but hey
check out the nation's top nanny for
those in East Chester who say that they
should still be able to buy a burger and
fries whenever they want well the town
says you still can just not here answer
is very simple they can travel to White
Plains mom Vernon Yonkers or New
Rochelle to get their fix of fast food
having already banned traditional
fast-food joints East Chester New York
recently decided to shield residents
from so-called fast casual restaurants
like Panera Bread cozy and most
tragically Chipotle what kind of a
monster would ban Chipotle you're saying
this was your idea tell us more no East
Chester is a very upscale community we
don't want to have fast food in our
community and we also decided that this
fast casual thing that's developing out
there wasn't something we wanted to have
Edith spoken like a man his lips have
never known the savory delights of
Chipotle he's Chester's supervisor
Anthony Colavito he's had to make the
town's restaurant scene as exciting as
his wardrobe any of the other
municipalities saying you know what you
know who do you guys think you are
serious sure of course people would
think that but we are East Chester and
that's us and we're not going to change
and we're like the way we are
I like that taking a stand oh yeah
follow me end of the month on Twitter
submit your nanny nominees and click
here to watch another episode
you